Anything you want,
you can get it.
We have people from
all cultural background.
We have Africans.
We have Jamaican.
We have persons
from all over.
Ghana, Nigeria,
Jamaica, Caribbean,
you know, everywhere.
You get it here.
You can choose
whatever you like.
Literally everything.
If you want a rug,
if you want curtains,
if you want food,
if you want fashion...
Anything
you can actually think about,
we've got it here.
I work in Edmonton Green
Shopping Centre.
I have been working
in this street market,
it's coming to one year
this month.
I'm a proud trader
in the Edmonton Green
Shopping Centre.
I been working here
almost a year now.
I've been working
north Edmonton Market
for about 18, 20 years.
It's a beautiful market.
It's a community.
It's a friendly one.
Young people, fun people,
elderly people.
My name is Ameya John-Lewis.
I sell African prints, lace,
and I'm a tailor. I combine
everything together.
The name of my shop is
Ameya World
Professional Style.
It's called Ameya World
because it's my world.
Why I choose that name?
I don't know.
It's my godfather
that chooses the name for me
because it's my real
native name.
My birth name.
I started making clothes
when I was young
because I grew up
seeing my mummy sewing
and every day I said,
"One day,
I'm going to be sewing."
So, when I grew up
I just fell in love with it
straight away.
Because
I love to do something,
I would like to be creative.
More or less,
I have self-taught passion.
I have passion
for what I do.
I'm from Nigeria.
Nigerian culture
is very beautiful.
We are very colourful
in terms of our party
and dressing up.
When I design for someone,
I sew for customer
and they like it.
They come back
and give me the review.
They're: "Ooh, Ameya,
thank you."
Ameya is a lovely woman.
Very focused,
hard working, consistent.
The first time I met her
she was so approachable.
Very good customer service.
The outfit
is very well-fitted.
Excellent.
On point.
She took her time.
Did a very beautiful job.
When I wake up
in the morning,
I know
I have a place to go to.
I will jump out of my bed,
I will run
like as if I'm going
to get a job in the office.
Even if I'm sick,
I'm always there.
I worked from home before.
When I said
I'm going to move my shop
to Edmonton Green
Shopping Mall,
my family was scared.
I said, "I will do it."
And by God's grace,
I started doing it
and the moment
everybody is telling me
I can't do it,
I keep doing it more.
So that is exactly
what put me
to where I am today.
My name is Marcia.
I am a hairdresser.
I have a passion for hair.
When I decided to do this
it was like...
I like to create stuff
and I like
to make people happy.
I like to see a smile
on people's face,
so I know
when I was quite younger,
I used to just play around
doing hair just for fun
and people
were really amazed.
Then I said maybe
I could just
use this as a profession
and it started from there.
My shop is
called Marcia's Salon
Just for people to recognise
it's Marcia.
I was going to use
Fabulous Hair, but no,
but no, Marcia.
People would know
exactly where we at.
The energy here,
some people come in
and said, "Oh, you're
always having a party!"
So that made me have
that vibey energy.
Me and my client,
we talk about
practically everything,
like relationship,
our lifestyle, men.
Practically every week
there's drama.
Drama being fun, laughter.
Somebody coming in
with something that just like,
you just have to just laugh.
You have to just
shake your head and laugh.
Every day is laughter
in my salon.
My name is Christine Oculi.
Our shop is called
Tony's Quality Butchers
because the meat is fresh.
Tony is an honour.
He's my son.
We name the shop
Tony's Quality Butchers
because Tony
had a butcher in Brixton,
so we thought it best
to keep the same name.
Tony is a very nice son.
Very polite,
very hard working.
James, my husband,
he's the best husband
anybody can ever wish for.
I wanted to become
a market trader
because I wanted to provide
for the whole community.
The food that people buy
from the shop
connects them to their
country, to their home.
Because when they come
to buy they will say,
"Oh, this is here also.
We got this in our country."
Sometimes we're playing
music and then, you know,
they are dancing
and then we also, you know,
join in and dance with them.
We crack jokes. We laugh.
Somebody might come
not very happy,
but by the time they leave
the shop, we talk to them,
and they go home laughing.
My name
is Rackel Ewan-Boulyn.
We sell a variety of stuff.
African-Caribbean stuff.
Things from, basically,
all over the world.
We have sugar cane,
sometimes watermelons,
all type of fruits,
yellow yam from Jamaica,
sweet potato.
We have Uganda sweet potato,
the puna yam,
and we have things connected
to a lot of countries,
a lot of cultures.
The food we sell
gives people
a feeling of being home.
When they're cooking
their food,
it reminds them that,
basically,
they're getting
a part of their culture.
Bertha is my mum.
-She's my auntie.
-She's my mum.
She's very determined
and hard-working.
When I think about my mum
is that
she's a wonderful person.
She is always kind
and helpful
even when somebody is sad,
she always cheers people up.
She's a good team leader,
she's also like a great,
great mum to me as well.
This job is not easy.
Being on your toes all day,
you have to keep
moving about,
always getting things
to stock up.
But in my case,
it's not hard
because I have help.
The workers
and the customers,
they are the best.
When they come
and they will tell you
a story
or they will run a joke
about something
or they just make your day.
The way
they talk to you is like,
some of the times
they don't want to leave.
My name is Fatou Inniss.
I've been working here
for one year now.
Dalston is a place
you can get a lot of things.
Mostly stuff from back home,
Africa, and Caribbean.
If you want something
from back home,
you can find what you need.
I'm selling
African products,
there're a few from Dubai,
and Caribbean food as well.
I got palm oil
from back home.
Awuchere, chagre.
My customer come and buy
their own country fruit.
You can see them,
their face.
they're so happy
when they're buying it.
When they come,
they're always happy.
Yes, please. Yes, please.
Being a female trader
in the market,
there are a few of us here.
Mostly men,
but it makes us special.
For me, I think
I can be equal as a man.
I look at equality,
person that can do the job,
so there's no difference
in a man or a woman
being a head of anything,
a company or business.
Can do it as a woman
as well as equal as a man.
Sometimes,
people look down at you
because it's like
it's not your role.
Well, at the beginning
it was not easy.
I have to get up
every morning and go work.
I'm hard worker.
I don't like
to depend with anyone.
I don't want to wait
for somebody
to come
and put food on my table
or to come
and put money in my hand.
I've been told I'm arrogant.
I've been told,
"You think you're all that."
And I've been told,
"You're a woman."
But, to me,
if you're strong
at something
and you like it
and you wanna do it,
I believe
that you should go for it,
whether you're man or woman.
I love my job.
The vibe of the people,
the music, the shouting.
Chocho, christophene.
You put in a soup.
You cook it done
with saltfish.
People are friendly.
Even though we don't know
each other that much,
but when you pass each other
we just say hello.
Doesn't matter
what colour you are,
English, Black.
-Get characters in Dalston.
-Innit.
You put it in your mouth
and your wiggly it around.
There's some things that
you only see in Dalston.
D'you know what I mean?
It's really loving here.
We have lovely people,
different character,
and different background.
I just love seeing people
you know, walking around,
talking,
different languages.
The Indian men,
they can speak everything.
Jamaican, they have little
African accents, everything.
It's Dalston,
it's multi-cultured.
Like you might hear
the Indian man
telling you "wagwan", so…
I was born in Lagos,
Nigeria.
I am from Jamaica.
I'm from Gambia.
Growing up in Jamaica
is awesome.
It's like
the best place to be.
The food,
the vibes of the people,
the parties.
A lot of the market
reminds me of Jamaica.
The clothes stalls,
the food stalls,
the shouting of the products
that we are selling,
the music.
I think that the ingredients
people buy from our shop
connects them
to their country.
It gives people
a sense of home.
Dalston always reminds me
of Ghana.
Everything around here
in the market
reminds me of home, Nigeria.
-Uganda.
-Jamaica.
-Gambia.
-West Africa.
And the people themselves,
they remind me of home.